[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
first of all Chris Rock and Wilson the
comedians that we're posting about it
it's like you have nothing in common
with Christian you were not you were
only Tech the way like some guy says
he's a podcaster yeah some guy off the
street has like 30 followers says he's
the way you and that guy have something
in common with podcasting that's the way
most people posting about Chris Rock had
you know what I mean like they're only
stand-ups in name only because she's a
[__] two of the most famous guys of
all time slapped each other it was
hilarious right it was really [__]
funny that somebody got slapped at the
Oscars yeah some guy who's been publicly
cut who's the most the most beloved man
in the world was cucked so hard his
brain melted 30 minutes before he was
going to win his Oscar like it was
incredibly incredible timing Will Smith
has been the most like Scientologist
manicured like public Persona Jada got
so much dick on the side that it [__]
melted his brain and he slapped Chris
Rock mom I mean he was just gonna win
his Oscar it was if that's not [__]
funny to you then what's the that's
hysterical it's a very funny situation
it's hysterical but now people are like
you know we're great truth tellers out
there and like yeah it could be me next
yeah exactly oh really it's you next and
[__] Magooby's Joke House which is my
home Club I love it in Timonium Maryland
no one is slapping you because you're
like what the my I don't get my wife
doesn't suck my dick enough no one is
about to slap you you [__] loser I
hated that [__] because it's like we're
complete I I come from a very like
comedians or clowns perspective right
I'm not listen I'm not making any
[__] points I'm not a point maker I'm
here to have a good ass time you know
what I mean just [__] talk about my
sexual like embarrassments like comedian
should be getting embarrassed right in
many ways getting slapped is the most
comedian thing possible the only thing I
would have liked is if Chris Rock would
have been like I mean how awesome would
it benefits like if he just talked about
Jada again getting cop on the side at
the Oscars only thing that heightens
that if he's like oh it smelled like
August Alsina's fingers
you just said something you know he
wanted to in his heart I saw it you can
see the like little flicker because
Chris Rock could have done that oh he
could have just eviscerated 100 he just
like you know he's like it was just a
big moment and you know he's a little
too rich probably yeah I mean maybe
Chris Rock 30 years ago does it 20 years
ago does it but that's what I'm saying
he's the [__] institution now he
can't he can't be firing back with the
true with the actual truth God would
have done it yeah oh I would have loved
you I I pray that's the other thing if
you're a real comedian you should be
begging Will Smith to slap you yeah
best thing in the [__] world once you
have a sales team or or or clients being
like well we need segments so we need we
want to sponsor this and sponsor that
and then it's like all right we can we
can do that but it's funnier when we're
just like yo that you were molested
yesterday
yeah and this is the body armor
molestation repressed memory of the week
Hassan actually told me is that which is
[__] hysterical is that Turks still
to this day the you can get out of
military service but you have to prove
you're gay and like in life and by the
way they don't count the guy who [__]
they're like real old world with it and
you like I was reading this article it's
so [__] funny they were asking the
guy because he had like a beard and they
were like they're like do you ever wear
women's clothing they
these [__] do not understand
what being gay is yeah and they wanted
him to send a picture of him wearing
makeup and women's clothes and he was
like that's not what being gay is he was
like will you let me send a picture of
me kissing a man and they were like
we'll accept that and there's like a
doctor who has to wow look at the
pictures and decide if you're gay enough
to be in the military
it's so [__] sick yeah yeah it is
[__] we were talking about
um
about like certain the most homophobic
cultures how they're kind of the gayest
they're absolutely there's like a bit
about this somewhere because the idea of
[__] a man is so out for ages walking
down the street like you could kiss you
could do whatever yeah because of course
none of you guys are gay yeah yo
literally they're not joking in a lot of
cultures like there's so much more male
affection because those cultures don't
have a lot of male to female affection
yeah yeah so they're looking for the
touch they just want you know people to
be more tactile and by the way we're
saying like oh it's so foreign they're
also like 100 molesting boys
[Laughter]
hey that's in the past
separate the artists from the artists
have you done that yeah I'm working on a
big words like [__] funny words like
well listen if we can if I can't listen
to R Kelly then you can't do geometry
Michelangelo Bernini Bernie's Italian
right but yeah yeah all these guys had
every yeah Pythagoras all these
[__] like you would teach a kid
madly suck him don't do that
I'm sorry if you know Pythagoras
you [__] did you just do the I
didn't mean there I didn't mean to I
tried not to I say gyro I don't go yiro
okay what I mean it was just so in my
head but that's a great [__] bit we
use not only the math but we we
appreciate the art of these dudes that
were like banging 100 [__] kids where
do we where do we draw the line you use
Pythagoras Theorem to draw that line
apples were little boys [__]
you're going to be obtuse when I'm done
with you
that Vice documentary about like I think
it was Colombia like a whole village
they had a showed up a culture of
[__] donkeys like no little boys like
that's how they reach sexual maturity
that's how they show them they're like
you gotta practice on this dog literally
so that you can make a woman come yeah
you can't even try on a woman until you
make this donkey come I don't think
they're interested in women coming I
don't think I think if you're in the guy
I think if you're if you haven't made it
past bestiality a woman's orgasm it's
not really at the top of your list
we'd formally like to invite you to a
case race in a future time a future time
I can do yeah we do we do case races on
this show I'll do it yeah Shane Gillis
is doing the next one with us oh Shane
will [__] destroy me he's a [__]
tank but it's teams of two okay nice I'm
gonna get in there though I'll get back
into my my drinking shape yeah puzzle
beers I bet I used to yeah not I'm more
of a weed guy these days oh really
overweed and dick pills guy these days
[Laughter]
let's see if I can stop my heart
oh there have been some close calls
Express in Tampa
[Laughter]
all right we're trying [__] old lady
in Tampa but that's a story for a
different it didn't work unfortunately
what do you mean your dick didn't work
or [__] oh she wouldn't come back to
the hotel we made out on a bench though
that's far that was cool yeah did you
get a handy at all uh a little bit
um and how old is old
she was she was early 60s okay mid 60s
maybe it's pretty old here's the thing
she was no she was old bro Believe Me
Brother I'll put it this way after we
made out on the way back my mouth was
numb and I'm pretty sure it was from
like denture cream
[Laughter]
no how about her what was her body type
what was her uh it was slim but I will
say hips intact hips intact there was I
didn't I didn't feel a screw I didn't
feel any aluminum you're forcing it but
I will say I did get a little handsy and
there was like where you'd expect
firmness there was a sliding situation I
was like oh interesting this is a
different and I was just like I was like
open I wasn't headline or anything I was
opening for Bob Bobby Kelly my guy he's
the funniest guy in the world he was he
would like let me open for him and he
had some friends in town we'd usually
just like hang out and like you know get
food afterwards we had some friends in
Tampa and I was like left to my own
devices that evening and this there was
like just during the show there was just
some [__] idiot that was ruining the
show just being like like yelling out it
was so annoying and it was that lady
what oh no then she like her friends
left her and she was just alone on a
park bench and I was just talking to her
and I was just like literally just
killing time until the Uber came
and but the Uber got lost and it was
like he was spinning around it was like
13 minutes so I'm like really chatting
up with this woman and that and she
started giving me like the look that
like you know a girl gives you when she
wants you to kiss her and then I was
like oh I was like not every old woman
is a grandma like yeah some of them some
like sometimes [__] just get old
I want to clarify the Old Bay comment
all right because that's like sacred it
is that's like an angel dust where you
exactly yes
shrimp crabs okay but these bozos up
here in Philly they put it on [__]
everything okay
crab fries are big where we I love them
you can't do you love them unimpeachable
crab fries are you out of your mind
really it's so [__] perfect thank you
a little bit of cheese on the side
around with it a little yeah absolutely
if you if you can recreate like a cream
of crab soup flip this guy knows about
right I'm on team stuff a little cream a
little cheese a little Old Bay get that
because listen we take a chowder we want
soup we want to liven up our fries
let the fries live what are we kidding
we both shop at the same store fully
sure I've seen that shirt on the on the
DXL wrap all right don't come at me
pretending you don't want different
variations of fries thank you it's not
like it's honest it's not a [__] it's
not a zero-sum game there's no need to
bring DXL into this they're good people
starving hey I love it don't hurt them
over there listen I'm back in
unfortunately nine months in a row of
touring I had to dip my toes
[Laughter]
how old are you I'm 31. wow you got to
tell your face and body yeah
Baltimore is one of the weirdest places
on Earth it's truly bizarre and I grew
up in I grew up in Greektown which is
like a fully isolated like little
neighborhood that's like that's like all
Greek people and but it's like it's
bordered by the most trash you've ever
seen in your life like it's totally like
yeah you have like Baltimore white trash
which is a beautiful blend of white
these are the people who wear the the
camera
oh yeah baby the [__] ravage let's
[__] go those [__] guys the guys
are like yeah Lamar's good but something
about Flacco that I missed I can't quite
put my finger on it but there was
something I trusted more about quacking
like those [__] guys traditionally
yeah yeah there was something bad or
just a pocket passer this guy's a
[__] running back that we're gonna
let him throw the [__] ball like
those guys yeah
um very I love those guys those pants
are my favorite thing is oh the purple
camo is unbelievable I don't think that
they were the only team that got them I
think that was one of the like NFL
initiatives of like the mid-2000s yeah
like okay our merch idea this year
because it was like right during the
Iraq War
USA stuff and they're like okay we're
gonna put out every team's colors and
camo shorts and every other fan base was
like yo These suck they stink and then
Baltimore was like [__] yeah Walter was
that oh these look pretty good yeah I'm
about to wear these to my child support
here and after this
yeah we won Ray won this one I'm about
to keep these for good luck and that
[__] ain't getting a Dom
I love those guys a bunch of those guys
were all like oh my God they were so
funny there was like counter protests in
Baltimore going on when Ray Rice got
suspended which is like is there a more
completely open and shut [__] this guy
thing we've ever seen in our lives and
these guys were all like this is [__]
[__] you know but right back on the
[__] field it's like I had yo I had a
cousin that worked over there at that
elevator [__] didn't go down the way you
think it was going down
yeah like it's so funny these [__]
idiots a comic's brand is so different
than a than a pedestrian's brain and
like what you know like I can't help I
want pedestrian is so funny by the way
I said I said to a woman
I said to a woman it's better than
civilian that drives me crazy it's like
we're not in the [__] Armed Force
let's [__] react there's a lot of
people that overuse that it's like we
are [__] so lucky we get to do this
[__] any person on the street I
respect more than even my favorite comic
let's put let's get that out there is
that like we we give so much less to
society than a [__] a janitor
but I know you but like but there's a
reason we're doing it right someone told
me he goes yeah but you know what we do
we give that person that's going through
the hardest day of their life we give
them a moment of of the prize and I go
yeah but we also send people through the
[__] roof yes we upset people
sometimes worse than anyone's ever upset
them in their [__] lives we never
think about the flip side yeah yeah we
got that one guy that's going through
cancer that's he's like oh thank God but
you got that one black chick yeah who
just stormed out oh yeah you've ruined
so many people's days and that's the
other thing it's like yeah we do that
but let's stop here's the thing drives
for casual comedians like that's not why
you do it no you know what you do it
because it's a lot better than [__]
being a paralegal you know what I mean
you do it because you can you can get
rich get [__] and just never have to
[__] write a spreadsheet again for
the rest of your life and no one's done
a [__] drug test you yeah yeah
exactly sleep in get [__] up let's all
relax with the I just do it to put a
smile on someone no you did it at least
for me I did it because when I was 19
this is how I got my dick sucked and
then it's been 15 years and I have no
other skills that's why I do it my mom's
English is a lot better than my dad's my
dad's just like you couldn't even have a
conversation with my father still he's
been in the country 40 years
um
[Applause]
he's speaking at us I would say seventh
grade level right now he's like he's
like he's like it's like talking to a
surly middle schooler
look you want to talk about Lumber you
want to talk about you know cabinets he
can talk that that's the only [__] he
can talk about
um so uh we're filling out FAFSA and
it's like um and they ask you like
what's your net worth that's one of the
questions and my mom says zero and I'm
like no Mom no I'm like I'm like she
doesn't [__] [__] immigrant
doesn't [__] know been in the country
doesn't know what net worth means and
I'm like no it means how much money we
totally have and she's like I know it's
zero
like what we have no money like I didn't
think we had a lot
zero money
how the [__] am I even alive
and it's like it's a testament to her
that I'm like I'm 18 and it never dawned
on me that we're my parents are just
massively in debt I worked at a law firm
and this is my one of my jobs before I
moved to New York because I needed to
save up money
um was I were I was a paralegal and I
didn't know what the law firm was and it
was like this trashy like Baltimore like
[__] suburb uh [__] office and I
realized pretty quickly that it was a
foreclosure law firm and they were
taking people's houses I was like well I
don't want to be a part of this like
this this is after the like this after
the housing crisis which is like people
were tricked you know yeah yeah I did I
was yeah I was working directly yeah
yeah federalized loans and all that [__]
yeah yeah like six months into working
on scene on CNBC like collateralized
debt is the problem I was like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's
that chicks out yeah
um I I got there and I was like well I
don't want to [__] work for these
people and I was like well I'll just
like stop working and like I'm sure
they'll fire me in like three or four
weeks Whatever by the time they figure
it out and I was just like in the
meantime I'm gonna go on two hour
lunches I'm gonna be the [__] you
know the life of the office I'm just
shooting this [__] with everyone
everyone loving because I'm not doing
work it's awesome
and it took them
literally like six months to fire me and
I just literally not doing anything I
was not do is when I was starting stand
up like I was pretty early on in my
career I was like doing open mics I'm
just writing [__] my boss would come by
I would hit the like Mouse to get the
screensaver but I was I wasn't logged in
so it would just be like oh my boss come
in and just be like the login screen
like it was I was like I was literally
playing like on my cell phone I was and
it was like I wasn't in I didn't have an
office I had cubicles out in the open it
was so completely disrespectful I was
begging to get fired and they just
wouldn't do it pushing when you're
playing blackjack or any cards or
whatever A push is the worst yeah
because you feel nothing yeah it'll make
me lose yeah at least take my [__]
money make me feel like [__] spitting my
[__] mouth owe me a [__] [__] you
know what I mean it's like that's the
equipment Casino every time you lose
[__] [__] take your money away you
[__] little [__] yeah it'd become it
become a BDSM absolutely tie you up and
hit you instead of the girl that comes
around with like drinks and cigarettes
she's like you want to be whipped you're
like get hit the [__] out of me yeah
yeah well I lose this hand why are you
hitting on 19 just let me just do it
tell me my dad's not proud of me
my dad had a choice New York he was 17
New York City or Buffalo this is in the
70s yeah and he saw like movies and was
like I'm not going to [__] New York
yeah yeah let me guess he had a real
Greek perspective on he was like I've
seen the movies about Harlem if you
catch him
definitely he was a little bit like I
want to avoid the inner city blacks
Greek uh racial sensitivity is not it's
certainly in the 70s was not exactly my
father I thought was racist my whole
life and then he married a black woman
wow interesting like recently that
doesn't mean he's not racist I you know
that's a good point
I think that's right Thomas Jefferson I
think we go all the way back
that's Strom Thurman literally had a
secret black wife yeah while he was like
we can't have blacks in schools
so I don't think that necessarily takes
your dad your Greek ass father off the
hook Roland Park is where I went right
it's a half hour from my [__] house
so my mom drives me there drives to work
like that's an hour her day takes me my
brothers couldn't get into that couldn't
get into that one
they weren't cutting the intellectual
mustard uh and and so they had to go to
it's still pretty good one Southeast but
close to our house so she's just
bouncing around my cousins yeah
exactly that school's hilarious my
brother his first day of sixth grade
right he's like a nervous little you
know you're still like a fat little
fifth grader who's like scared you're
like oh what's Middle School gonna be
like first day he goes to the bathroom
a kid this kid who had probably failed
like four times in a row he's like 16
years old an eighth grader who's like
got stubble he was driving yeah he sees
my brother's like hey yo let me get your
pants
that's his first this first day in
middle school and my brother just just
[__] Sprints Sprints back the
homeroom right the whole [__] so
you're not doing the Bitcoin the nfts on
that all that is [__] you're a
[__] dumb [__] if you have any of
that and I want to be very clear about
you hear that ma yeah for some reason
there was like we we played like a group
of Arab kids that were playing football
with us and they like a bunch of them
just started [__] us like sucker
punched us and one kid cleated me on the
[__] face and then my friend uh my
friend called his brothers and
it was we were like maybe 14 like the ad
was our age like we were somewhere
between the ages were like 12 to like 16
and a car full of like 27 year old Greek
men with bats came out just like
threatened these children wow
yeah was this free 911 this was
it must have been post it must have been
post well that adds to the heatedness
yeah absolutely you know a lot of delis
that's right yeah like gambling it's
like it's never gonna get like that for
me the way like drugs even it's like I
like drugs but I'm never I could quit
anything cool I could quit like [__]
booze was so easy like weed is a lot
harder for me it's it's weed food and
trying to get my little dick sucked
those are the three things that I'm just
in that order no no I think it would go
food [__] Weed and [__] Weed food is
the Destroyer for me dude food is way
bigger than [__] it's absolutely but
food and [__] together has that been a
thing love nothing better than getting
[__] sucked off the Uber she's in the
Uber there's a [__] half a cheese
stick waiting for me brother and I got a
[__] ice cream cone in the fridge
that got special you know that's all
you're really thinking about it's like
this the moment I bust that's all I'm
thinking about it's like it's like the
second the evil the poison is out of my
body I'm thinking let's put a different
kind of poison in
as that one goes in the best ones are
not the ones that know the actual facts
because yeah in some ways it's like 911
was somewhat [__] up [__] either they
let it happen or I don't even think they
had a direct hand because why would you
it's just like yeah we'll do this and
then we'll use it as oh this is gonna
happen don't stop it yeah and then we
can go [__] up Arabs for like two
decades you know like we don't give a
[__] the I don't want to know the real
reason what I love is the people that
believe the dumbest [__] of all time and
say it's like I love Greek people anti
some of the biggest anti-semitis have
you ever heard the one where it's like
the trains didn't stop they were taking
gold out from underneath yeah my
favorite one is my favorite one that
I've heard like old Greek men say not
joking is like you know uh every Jew
called out on 9 11.
it's like check the records every single
Jew called in sick and it's like really
you think every Jew was in just like a
Jewish janitor was in on it and they do
believe it we have a newsletter that
somehow in in the Hebrews and no one
else no one else is on there no no one
warned anybody else uh they're like but
I have a buddy who's not Jewish who
works there yeah yeah exactly keep your
mouth shut yeah so no one's married to a
non-jew
it's so great
those are the best ones where it's like
that's one of the most [__] things
I've ever heard in my life do you know
Amy Schumer's baby's name she didn't
realize that she did this because she
loves Dave Attell yeah so much you know
as we all do and I think it might be the
Godfather for kid or something but she
named her kid he's the father actually
David Davis that's right she named her
kind of a George single Christianity
situation and then whatever the
husband's last name is Jean attel so she
was like he was like two months old I
was like I named my kid genital
you didn't realize until he was two
months old that you had to legally
change his middle name she's like I
messed up that's so funny she was doing
it that's kind of hurt a comedian's
feelings it's like if you're getting
bumped from the middle name
it's Seinfeld now it's just Seinfeld
it's Jean Red Skelton
before he got trouble she goes I'm Gonna
Change it to Gene Cosby yeah
literally having a flashback of making
steaks on the grill I put illegally on
our balcony in Greektown I love that I
had a summer of grilling charcoal it was
a gas grill okay this was a gas grill
even more dangerous but all right yeah
thank you
[Music]